you ready go for it
this sir will kill
the German Halbert my name is Philip
Baldwin Fame is a curious thing being a
winner in the show might be a game
changer and I don't really have that
much time left I'm all
used by Swiss armies during the Medieval
Era the halberd was versatile and Lethal
Weapon of War
a combination of Spike hook and ax it
was a triple threat but soldiers would
defend themselves against Knights on
Horseback by using its back hook to
catch and Dismount their opponents and
then move in for the kill using the
spear point to thrust or the ax to slice
through armor an Infamous killer King
Charles the Bold the Duke burgundy met
his fate when his head was halved by a
Halford ending the burgundy a Wars in
1477.
this is byhander
my name is Jay replogle ever since I was
a kid Kung Fu Fighting my brother you
know with sticks in the backyard I've
always had a fascination with knives and
bladesmith thinks it's just the mature
level of that I guess
this vihander which means two-hander in
German was a massive sword wielded by
Swiss and German mercenary armies in the
16th century sometimes stretching to
over six feet in length the zyhander was
a long sword featuring an extended grip
in Broad Garden as European armies
employed more Pikes and pole arms on the
battlefield the zyhander emerged as a
counter weapon this enormous sword was
used to break up Pike formations by
cutting spear ends and opening up holes
in Enemy Lines due to its size the
spyhander was only wielded by the
biggest and most audacious soldiers if
these soldiers survived charges into
enemy Spears they would often be paid
double for their substantial risk the
zweihander eventually faded from the
battlefield but survives today in games
such as Dark Souls
Albert has an ax on one side a hook on
the other side of a spike the bottom
kicks into a wood shaft The Originals
were not forged in one piece and that's
the approach that I'm going to take
the most challenging element is going to
be making the central cross it's a very
compact 4G
foreign
would be easier to just fabricate it to
get something that looks okay at 200
yards but this show is not fabricated in
fire it's forged and Fire
it is a tricky shaking problem I'm
drawing on everything I know
I'm no professional halberd maker that's
for sure
it's almost done the problem is it's
just too thick
sharpening the blades took a lot longer
than I thought it would there was a lot
more metal on the edge than it looked
like
I'll let the judges
do their worst
here we are in Sparta Tennessee at my
shop
my game plan is to First do a design and
then we'll just go straight to forging
the sword is just epic I mean this is as
big as it gets as far as swords go so
it's going to be a real challenge
I've never made anything this big I mean
the overall things gonna be five feet
it's a physical challenge as much as it
is you know a forging challenge you know
it's like CrossFit forging or something
but clock sticking you gotta get it done
so far it's coming together really good
my grind marks beat up right here in the
center really good
it's time to quench
getting an even heat over such a long
piece it's definitely make or break you
know the quench doesn't go good we're
gonna have to start all over
when you have a five foot blade that
means you have to have almost a five
foot quench tank this can be pretty bad
if the quench doesn't go good we're
gonna have to start all over
sweet
didn't break
didn't break that's what I was hoping
for
now I can start working on the guard
I put the wiggle shapes in it so today
I'm going to wrap the handle in leather
and it'll make a super tough handle that
you should be able to take the impacts
string helps everything
nice and tight
this boy's a beast it's going to be able
to take some punishment and deal some
punishment
laughs
foreign
[Music]
see what kind of little damage your
Halbert will do we'll take your halberd
and deliver thrust hacks and attempt to
Dismount that dummy with its hook fill
your first you ready for this yes sir
[Music]
all right Phil your spear tip is sharp
not only at the point but its edges also
your accent not only did it dig in and
break the ribs it went in and cut the
internal organs that were behind their
ribs and their hook played it dug into
the ribs and dismounted the Dummy from
the horse overall your weapon here will
kill thank you good job Jacobs you ready
go for it let's do this
all right
foreign
it is a heavy weight and it's harder to
manipulate with multiple blows but on
the thrust I was able to go in one side
and all the way
on the opposite side of the dummy
yes sir We'll Kill
thank you test the strength and
durability of your halberds I'll be
chopping into this corrugated sheet
steel remember this test is all about
what a steel does to your Hubbards and
not what your halberds do to the steel
fill you up first you ready yes sir
thank you
well Phil your Hubbard held up perfectly
all of the faces on it are still razor
sharp there's no deformation that I can
see
overall very well done thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test now
the zioner was often used against Pike
formations so I'm going to take yours by
handers and go against a rack of Pikes
here five times with each of your blades
see how far it can break through
Jay you're up are you ready ready
[Music]
wow
when you start swinging this thing it
moves things out of its way
I don't see any damage to your Edge
nicely done thank you
all right bladesmiths to test the
sharpness of your blades I'll be cutting
through these fish using both the blade
and the tip of your halberds now a good
sharp blade should cut through those
fish nice and clean
Phil you ready go for it
[Music]
all right the cuts look very clean
they're just nice slices
I really like the design of this weapon
the handle feels good it's got some heft
to it but it's balanced nicely but most
off it's definitely a sharp weapon you
built the cutter good job thank you sir
test the sharpness of your Edge I'm
going to cut into this bundle of sugar
cane twice once with either side
Jay you're up are you ready ready as I'm
ever going to be
it's got a lot of weight to it but
obviously it's plenty sharp nicely done
thank you
two blades One champion you decide the
winner forged in fire war of weapons